je vends ma ds politique comme une forme
de résistance pour pas laisser dire et
faire n'importe quoi pour que les gens
puissent se fiait des relais sincère
honnête parce que tu trouves honnête et
sincère de parler politique avec un
point de vue aussi clairement situé que
le tien croyez-vous qu'on peut vivre
pendant 10 ans auprès de quelqu'un et ne
pas le connaître quand tu me regardes tu
trouves pas je ressemble à un canton
suisse profil d'une neutralité absolue
regard clair et franc
toi tu es le roi de la dissimulation
parfois on se laisse dépasser par les
événements on se laisse submerger par
nos émotions
moi je crois que la prise de décision va
être de plus en plus compliqué de plus
en plus raffinés
je suis dans une période hyper flou
tiens regarde en libye par exemple
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
tu veux la connaître la dernière
évolution je couche avec dsk
tu crois quoi paul à la fidélité en
politique
ouais le premier droit des femmes c'est
le droit d'être conne aussi bêtement et
sottement conne que certains hommes sont
autorisés de crétins voilà encore une
fois il s'est passé quelque chose
d'incroyable et donc sa recrue
conducteur mais quelle surprise
un coup de fil à 3h du mat pour te dire
quoi non mais tu te fous de ma gueule en
fait je pense bière ton factotum l'ombre
de ton nom de l'ombre de ton chien mais
tu te fous de ma gueule
c'est bien qu'il ait pu raconter sa
vérité à claire chazal vérité c'est
qu'il a failli planter toute la gauche
le libertin assumer reconnaît la faute
morale et les bras m'en tombent
ce jeu de madame fération dingue ans sa
froideur son manque crise temps pluvieux
pote jeudi raté un épisode
ségolène martine dominique laurent
arnaud françois tu crois que ça fait un
paysage mental toi peut-être pas mais
détends-toi lâcheté fixette
il ya une vie en dehors de la gauche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]